good morning good afternoon and good
evening
i'm excited to talk with you all today
about limbs and data integrity and the
age of covid
my name is dr christine pascoe
so here is a quick agenda of our
presentation today
a brief introduction to lim's data
integrity as well as best practices
we'll take a look at what exactly data
integrity is
what a lims is a laboratory information
management system
we'll examine positive id as well as
instrument integration
monitoring with sensors which are
becoming incredibly important in today's
laboratory
and then finally we'll take a look at a
number of case studies
and finish with a summary
okay if we look at the term data
integrity and we look up the definition
data integrity is defined as generating
transforming maintaining as well as
assuring the accuracy
completeness and consistency of data
over its entire life cycle so from the
minute that data is generated
until anyone looking at that data years
later
and then also in compliance of course
with all the applicable regulations
some agencies have dates for how long
that data needs to be managed maintained
and stored
so having said that one of the
interesting things that i had searched
was what the priorities were for
technology
initiatives for 2020 and i wanted to see
how many
technology initiatives had to do with
data integrity
and there's a lot that had to do with
security and
digital transformation of course cloud
internet of things um but there were
very few that focused on
ensuring that there was high quality
data i would say in this um
in this list it's probably the the fifth
one down
seventeen percent of respondents said
that automation was a priority and
some of automation um is related to data
integrity
so that you know it is making an
appearance on the graph
but here's the statistics 40 percent of
businesses report losing tens of
thousands of dollars
or more because of poor data quality so
you know not only is there financial
incentives to making sure that data
quality
is is high and data integrity exists
but there's also the company's
reputation now the decisions that are
made based on that data
and ensuring that the individuals that
work in that laboratory can be proud of
the work that they do
next we're going to take a look at a few
characteristics of data integrity
many of you may have heard the term
alcoa well
alcoa refers to attributable
who acquired the data legible
can you read and understand the data
contemporaneous
were the records documented at the time
of the
experiment or the activity original
is this the first recorded observation
or a verified true copy of that data
accurate is the data or the result
scientifically valid and error free
and then complete means all the data
including any reruns or re-analysis that
were performed recorded
consistent all elements of the data
analysis
are date and time stamped and in the
correct sequence
enduring data is recorded in a permanent
maintainable form throughout its life
cycle
available the data is ready for review
and inspection
or an audit as long as that data exists
in the database
next i want to share with you something
that i found when i was doing my
research
understanding data integrity failure so
when data integrity isn't maintained
i was really surprised to learn that 80
percent of
failures are unintentional and if they
looked at root causes
it was often performance in business
pressure a lack of
awareness or capability data integrity
was not integrated into the company's
dna
or there was inadequate processes or
resources and technology
to achieve data integrity and these were
just a few that were
uncovered during a root cause analysis
so now if we want to look at addressing
data integrity failures and finding out
actions that companies can take to
create a culture where
data integrity is is integral
it starts with education and
communication rewriting sops
standard operating procedures for for
team members and subject matter experts
understanding and detecting risk
defining a strategy for
data integrity as well as technology so
that you can have date and time stamps
on the data so that you can have
computerized limb systems that can
greatly assist the analyst with
not only collecting their data but
managing it and maintaining it
making sure that there's electronic
audit trails
and then finally establishing a
governance
structure for data integrity
now if we look at some compromises and
data integrity
it can be human error either accidental
or malicious
it can be transfer errors including
unintended alterations
if someone's dyslexic they can have
transcription errors
if someone's rushed or in a hurry if
they have too much work
their error rate can go up there can be
bugs or viruses
hackers or other cyber threats to the
organization that can
modify data compromised hardware
such as a disk crash physical compromise
to devices
since only some of the compromises are
adequately prevented through data
security
the case for data backup and duplication
is really critical
in ensuring data integrity in most
disaster recovery plans for
iso audits today must
include an aspect of storing the data
off site so
either a backup in the cloud or
oftentimes people will take a physical
backup
to another location each evening so that
the data is not
all in one location
now if we look at limbs and this
overview slide of how a limbs can help
promote data quality we see that
what the arrows are points where the
limbs can really strengthen data
integrity
first off is positive id so leveraging
barcoding whether it's 1d
or 2d or also rfid
making sure that the samples are
adequately tagged so that they're not
lost and they can be
traced around the laboratory looking
at metrics key performance indicators as
you can view in
dashboards and these dashboards can be
per employee so each employee can see
what they need to monitor for that day
perhaps at samples that
need to be analyzed before they have
expired so before their
whole time has has come up looking at
reports
so being able to have a final copy of
the analytical result
or it could be a work list report that
goes to an analyst
so all these are tools that will help
the laboratory stay on track
making sure that they manage and
maintain the data properly
having an integrated scheduling function
is also very powerful
and that not only will it allow you to
pre-label
samples that you know the laboratory
will be receiving back so a lot of that
data can already be
in the database so when the sample is
received it can be
a session very quickly schedules are
also very good for
setting up automated reminders for
things like
employee training records when training
will
expire so that you can schedule
retraining also for instrument
calibration if an instrument is going
out of calibration you don't want to
wait till the day
it's going to be uncalibrated or the day
before you want to make sure that you
have time to plan
looking at instrument integration this
allows data to move electronically from
the instrument right into the limbs
some of the more modern limbs will or
more modern instruments will also allow
the limbs to send the work list to the
instrument
the instruments loaded in the correct
order the samples are run
the data is generated and it's sent back
to the limb so
because that entire process is
electronic
there's no room for transcription errors
and then also
integration with third-party
applications whether it's sap
an erp accounting package so again
you're moving that data electronically
and reducing errors
and then the ability to have a tablet
where you can collect
data either at the bench or in the field
and again you're eliminating paper
you're introducing an electronic audit
trail people must log in with their
credentials so you know that
who will does what by when um and you
have that traceability
and also if results are changed you can
see who changed them and why
next we're just going to quickly talk
about instrument integration
when you have a limb system it's just
smart it has a very fast return on
investment
it avoids duplication it increases your
accuracy and your throughput
it also translates into higher employee
satisfaction because they don't have to
re-enter data from instruments
now the way it works is really pretty
straightforward
instruments will output files in a
number of different formats whether it
be a csv
comma separated value in excel format
xml what have you and you basically take
that instrument output file
and create a parser that takes that data
output file and puts it into a format
that the lims is able to input
so some of the modern instruments also
have the ability to receive a work list
so in those cases the limbs can generate
a work list that's sent to the
instrument
the instruments loaded the samples are
run the
analysis results are sent back to the
limbs and it can all happen
very quickly because it's all electronic
laboratories can also set up parsers to
import data from contract testing
laboratories they can
implement barcodes on their work list to
very quickly load
instruments so that that data can very
quickly
be electronically uploaded back into the
limbs and you can
also have an error log so that there are
any problems you can investigate those
but it's very efficient and effective
way to to do your work when you have a
very high throughput laboratory
especially
next because laboratories are such
dynamic places
um having the ability to to leverage
sensors for remote monitoring
is huge because it eliminates paper in
the laboratory no more paper
temperature charts or hand recording of
temperatures every morning
the sensor in the in the piece of
equipment whether it's an incubator
fridge freezer what have you
it'll take readings um every 15 seconds
record that to the cloud
and also it can be averaged and placed
into the limbs
automatically so that a task that would
take an employee
a few minutes each morning can very
quickly be eliminated
and you can also get real-time alerts if
there's a problem
with a piece of equipment so really it's
cheap insurance and also provides
regulatory compliance and one less
task that the analysts need to worry
about
okay we've just talked about a number of
ways that limbs and laboratory
automation help laboratories
maintain their regulatory compliance as
well as increase efficiency
productivity as well as profitability
everything from positive id
sample tracking leveraging barcodes
having that traceability within the
laboratory
data entry being automated with
instrument integration
being able to set up calculations that
can be
verified and validated and then locked
so that only the lym
system administrator has the ability to
make any changes
again with an audit trail the ability to
perform statistics
on that data having a very sophisticated
sample scheduling function that will
allow you to set up reminders for
when equipment needs calibration or
employees need retraining
is is wonderful because there's so much
information to keep track of if you're
managing a laboratory
making sure that specimens and supplies
are stored at the correct temperatures
with the
temperature monitoring solutions and
then also having
enhanced communication throughout your
laboratory because
you don't need to run around from
section to section you can just log into
the limbs
and check on the progress of the
analysis of the sample
and then finally the ability to have
automated reporting so this
manual task can be eliminated next we're
going to examine three
data integrity failures related to the
covid pandemic
first we'll examine what happened when
the cdc created a covid test kit
then we'll look at the rejection of
sampling kits by the canadian government
and finally we'll look at challenges
with vaccine development
the u.s government via the cdc was
tasked to
create and distribute covet testing kits
to all the health departments throughout
the united states
headlines soon appeared that the cdc had
botched the coronavirus testing
further investigation found that the
test kits that were sent to hundreds of
state and local
public health departments across the
united states were contaminated so their
negative control was actually coming up
positive and many
public health labs didn't realize the
test wasn't working properly and they
were reporting false positives
and as you can imagine this led not only
to quite a bit of
confusion early on but it was very
difficult to do
tracing of positive patients in terms of
who they were in contact with the
assisting containing the outbreak
because some of the
positives weren't really positives so as
you can imagine
the fda came in to investigate the cdc
and they had a number of questions for
the cdc team
and what they found was not only there
was a
contamination of their negative control
but they also found that two of the
three cdc labs that were located in
atlanta
didn't follow their own manufacturing
guidelines they didn't follow the
standard operating procedures that
should have been linked in their limbs
to the manufacturing of test kits
they found that there was a huge lack of
expertise and
and training uh the positive and
negative controls were made in the same
room
and for anyone familiar with pcr when
you're performing pcr you're
amplificating
nucleic acid and during that
amplification
there's nucleic acid in the air so it's
very important to change
clothing there was no changing of the
lab coat so the people that were
performing the pcr were also the people
that were making the negative controls
and that's how they determined they were
contaminated
the cdc took more than a month to
correct the issue and that really
hindered efforts by the public health
officials to limit the early
spread of coronavirus in the united
states
so when the fda reported their findings
there were
multiple things that went wrong the
negative control was contaminated for
the coronavirus test
they also noted that other countries had
created a single test for a single
target
whereas the united states of the cdc
created a single test but they had
multiple targets
they didn't just target the sars
cove ii they also targeted other sars
viruses
and by making the test so complex i
think it contributed
to the failure of the test it was
interesting that there was no final qc
before the test were shipped
because if anyone did use the test they
would have known right away that the
negative control would have failed
so you know in a limb system you can set
up limits like pass fail if it fails
then it can't be released so there's a
lot of automation
that either wasn't used or people
weren't trained in the proper use of
also the fda rules initially prevented
the state and commercial labs from
developing their own coronavirus test
kit
so even if they could develop it and had
the expertise they weren't able to
so this also delayed testing because the
cdc was the only shot
at creating a test and then the
cdc and the fda reversed course and they
lifted that rule at the end of february
so that other
commercial as well as university
laboratories were allowed to create the
coronavirus test kit as well
so there were a lot of things that came
into play here but
they were able to understand what went
wrong and work with private companies to
create
viable test kits next we're going to
look at
a case study with the canadian
government how they had rejected not
only nasal swabs but also
coronavirus testing kits when testing is
done on reagents and supplies in the
laboratory
oftentimes the vendor will ship with
those reagents what's called a c of a
a certificate of analysis so in the case
of
nasal swabs or petri plates typically
the c of a will state that the
item was tested and found to be sterile
so that means that when they put it on
microbiological media
nothing was cultured nothing grew the
ontario government received over a
hundred thousand contaminated unusable
swabs for covet testing
how did they know this they basically
didn't
they did they want to verify the
manufacturer's
certificate of analysis and they did
their own testing and when they
um incubated covid testing swabs they
found out that they were contaminated
with what they believed was mold so
there were
over a hundred thousand contaminated
swabs that were unused
early on in the pandemic when they were
trying to identify
positive patients a second example from
the canadian government
is uh more than 6400 test kits were
contaminated
prior to being used thankfully they
found that
they were contaminated with the bacteria
the previous one was contaminated with
the mold
and if you realize that these
nasopharyngeal test kits
are meant to basically go into someone's
sinuses and if they're contaminated you
could be inoculating people with mold or
bacteria
it's a very scary proposition so it's
really um
wonderful that they determined that they
were contaminated and did not use them
but i often wonder how many cases where
people were in such a hurry to
screen people so that they could contain
the outbreak and they didn't do testing
on the materials that they received too
often people believe the manufacturers
certificate of analysis they have a lot
of faith in that
and other organizations often do some
form of lot testing so they may not test
every single sample
but they'll test you know one percent or
five percent
to make sure that the c of a is accurate
so if we look at the coronavirus
pandemic it really was the perfect storm
there were so many factors involved
early on
the data that the government presented
to
the people was that mass don't work and
it came out that it
wasn't that mass didn't work they didn't
want people to purchase masks because
there weren't enough masks for the
healthcare workers
also only the cdc could make the kova
test kit and they picked their primers
and probes
to target even though other countries
had already created test kits so there
really is no standardized test kit
everyone's using different test kits
that they've created within their
country
multiplex versus a single test the cdc
made a much more complex
coronavirus test initially and that
later they moved to a single target
single test configuration
other negative controls were
contaminated we've also found out that
some of the laboratories ran the cycles
too long so that everything would come
up positive
so with all the false positives out
there it was really difficult to
understand
the true picture of the the outbreak in
the country
there was a shortage of ppe a lot of it
was coming from
china there were quality issues
hospitals were overwhelmed
in many cases in italy where people were
on life support they were making
decisions based on the age of the
patient so it was a really horrible time
later masks do work where to if it makes
you feel safe so
there was so much misinformation
confusing information being
provided then finally we write about
contaminated vaccines where
millions of doses were disposed of and
all the while there were cases cases
cases clusters
of the outbreak continuing and then just
boom
full-blown pandemic
our final case study is looking at
manufacturing issues
vaccine development challenges by
pharmaceutical companies
all related to product quality there's a
manufacturing
facility called emergent they were
located in baltimore they were actually
making the vaccines for both
johnson and johnson as well as
astrazeneca
as you can imagine the fda
began to investigate once again and they
found that the facility in baltimore had
numerous
challenges that they were dealing with
the vaccines were released to ship
but no one really could attest to the
quality of the vaccines they were sent
to canada and mexico
astrazeneca's vaccine that was made at
the same facility as the johnson and
johnson vaccine was made
they discarded millions of doses and
they said they
because they were potentially
contaminated i don't know if any data is
going to be available because the cdc or
the fda
is still investigating but they had over
15 million doses
that were discarded because of
contamination what the fda did report
is that there were problems with
disinfection practices
the size and design of the facility the
way in which the workers were handling
the raw materials
and also training of the workers
so if we look at the impact of having a
culture
of poor data integrity you can see that
bad data can cause a lot of problems
the most important is loss of life in
the first few months of a pandemic
they're critical in containing an
outbreak
and there was an opportunity lost with
the defective test kits
the financial loss in the billions i'm
sure maybe even higher
political outfall the reputation loss of
trust of the
testing laboratories of the
manufacturers that are creating
not only the test kits but the
nasopharyngeal swabs
but the vaccine so there's a lot at
stake to get it right
and when you embrace a a
culture of data integrity things go
right much more often than in companies
that
don't embrace data integrity
now because many of the investigations
by the fda are ongoing
we don't have a final report of what
happened in terms of details with the
coronavirus test kit that was botched or
the vaccines
or the nasopharyngeal swabs but what we
can do is look at examples of integrity
issues from past
fda audits they found that
analysts in the laboratory save files to
a personal computer not on a network
they found that users were sharing
passwords because they didn't want to
pay for software licenses to basically
save
cost they often find that the audit
trail is disabled
so that people can change results
without providing a reason or
explanation
a lack of training for laboratory staff
we saw that as an initial finding
by the fda in the creation of the covet
kits at the cdc
they've also detected hplc integration
parameters that were changed and re-ran
until results passed in other labs
quality tests were not performed i think
it's clear to
say this is what happened at the cdc no
one tested the test kits before
they were sent to hundreds of
laboratories across the united states
the standard operating procedures were
not followed that was another finding of
the fda of their initial investigation
of the coronavirus test kit manufacturer
at the cdc
unsanctioned sample testing with labels
such as demo test
blank or trial inadequate access control
so when you
have a limbs you can basically give
analysts different roles within the
limbs and you can assign them privileges
so
an analyst can maybe enter their results
and validate their results but they're
unable to approve them that would be a
supervisor
and that's just an example of having
peer control or peer review
in your laboratory so those were not
configured or were
configured improperly users were logged
in to a shared account so that they
could change data without
understanding who actually changed the
data so there are a number of ways that
people can
get around controls that are put in
place to have good quality solution
now if we look at a few methods that
which support data integrity
one under best practices is to execute a
risk-based validation
so what is this it basically takes
validation and puts it into three
categories say
hi where the failure would severely
affect safety or quality process
medium a failure would have a moderate
impact on the safety and quality
processes
or a low where a failure would have a
minor impact on
patient safety or product quality so by
using this matrix you can basically
define steps in your process that
require
more attention versus those that may not
be as critical also ensure that partners
and vendors are iso certified this
basically means that their regular
regularly audited by a external party
to ensure that their quality management
system is adhering to the guidelines of
the international standards organization
so you know that that vendor has a
quality system in place versus
a vendor that you found on the internet
and has no quality system and no
certifications
look at the audit trail reports of the
limbs how often are results changed is
it something that happens
very frequently or does it happen not at
all
there's a lot of information to be had
in the audit trail report
i'm looking at the change control
process does the laboratory have one
how does it work are the end users
trained in this process
quality i t and validate systems how is
the
what role does the information
technology team play
with the limbs how do they help the
laboratory do they have documentation
that systems have been validated that
calculations
are accurate and concise do they have
documentation on instrument integration
where is that data going from the
instrument
in the limbs what fields is that data
being placed into
does the organization have a business
continuity plan so if they lose power
or if their all their data becomes
corrupt where's the backup located is it
off site
is it how long would it take to get that
database up and running again i'm also
providing data integrity training to
their analysts
is this something that is in the the
organization's dna or is this something
that people
are not even familiar with and then also
also looking at
how the data is archived and also
checking those
archives of those backups because it's
one thing to say yes we back up our data
you know twice a day or or every five
hours but it's another to take a look at
that to make sure that the backups
are backing up correctly
so in summary bad data is not only
dangerous
dangerous it can be deadly as we've just
seen automation enhances data quality in
that there's no
opportunity for transcription errors it
can occur in the background in the case
of sensors and i'll be recorded
and only provide alerts when there's a
problem
eliminating transcription errors is huge
because you know you have a higher
quality of data
and you don't waste valuable resources
re-entering results from an instrument
into a limbs
also by having sensors that are
calibrated to the nest standards your
you know that your
have calibrated equipment that's taking
measurements and you are
in compliance so when you have your
regulatory audits you have the data to
to back that up there's also an audit
trail so that any changes
made within the database especially to
any results are
documented you've tracked the who what
when why
you have date and time stamps of when
changes to data were made
by whom and what the reason for the
change was and that there's also data
security
to ensure that no one can go in and
alter data
so that you basically have a username
and password the system is
21cfr part 11 compliant with electronic
signatures
and also the cost of bad data can not
only shut down a business and hurt a
company's reputation
but it can have lasting consequences far
beyond a bad audit
it can lead to death as we've seen in
this
current pandemic now i don't want to end
the presentation on a negative note
but i do want people to realize the
importance of data integrity and data
quality
it really does matter if anyone's
interested in learning more or
would like a copy of the presentation
please feel free to reach out thank you
so much for your time have a wonderful
rest of your
day or evening or morning thank you